avoir 20 ans et parfois se rêvait
artistes et espérer vivre de son art la
pandémie qui a mis à l'arrêt le monde de
la culture ces deux dernières années
rend le pari parfois plus osé que
d'habitude amélie une jeune danseuse
installé à chalon tentent de relever le
défi c'est notre rubrique avoir 20 ans
elle est signée marine baratte et
tiphaine failli faire pour les images
c'est dur d'avoir un temps
[Musique]
je m'appelle amélie ultima j'ai 21 ans
et je suis étudiante au conservatoire du
grand chalon en danse contemporaine
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup la danse parce que c'est
une façon de le ressentir son corps
chaque personne dans son corps à se
placer dans l'espace pour que ça donne
quelque chose d'intéressant
s'accrochèrent
j'ai commencé très jeune comme beaucoup
danseurs finalement et j'ai accroché
d'abord avec la danse classique et puis
il ya trois ans je suis arrivé en
contemporain parce qu'on m'a dit que
finalement dans le corps j'étais plus
contemporaine et effectivement ça a très
bien fonctionné
[Musique]
si je venais de terminer ma licence
lettres aux dernières vivent à cergy en
parallèle du conservatoire et mes
professeurs m'ont parlé justement du
cursus cps dont classes préparatoires
aux écoles supérieures et ils m'ont
conseillé très rapidement chaland parce
que c'était m'ont dit que c'était à lui
assez actif au niveau 2 de la danse
contemporaine et l'art contemporain en
règle générale et puis qu'il y avait une
bonne équipe pédagogique
tout ça est donc je vais tester
l'audition j'ai été prise un
homme élite une très belle personne est
il si important dans le monde de la
danse à 10 et des danseuses et de
l'artiste avec cette philosophie avec
cet état d'être qui a qui émane d'elle
elle est très solaire et on aime
beaucoup travailler avec elle mon envie
qu'elles partent très vite qu'elles
puissent intégrer une école supérieure
ou directement de compagnie
c'est notre objectif dans ce
conservatoire
vous avez faim mais pourquoi
ce choix
[Musique]
je déjeune avec janet il dit
on s'est rencontré en début d'année tous
les vendredis midi on mange ensemble on
a souvent tendance à beaucoup discuté de
danse et de plein de choses autres
mais c'est vrai que c'est un milieu
assez
compétitifs mais ça empêche pas de créer
de vrais liens et puis même de centre et
est parce qu on oublie un peu qui a pas
que des relations négative disant et
puis au contraire faut s'appuyer aussi
sur les autres pour avancer parce que
sinon on se noie en fait
comme on est à 3 concède à remonter
moralement parce que basse et ça s'est
compliqué parfois on est très vite
découragés on est prise par vidéo
cette année à chalon on s'entraide
beaucoup et du coup ça nous pousse fermé
organisé en fait pour par exemple ont
filmé pour les auditions on est très
organisée et il y en a une qui met la
musique une qui filme l'os qui danse
après on inverse et ça c'est super
ça va s'asseoir en garde j'ai juste un
peu de cafouiller dedans mais s'ajuste
la fin sinon c'est bien
[Musique]
c'est celui là que ça fait mal oui mais
en ce moment j'ai mal à leur stage parce
que j'ai en première phase je prends
apprend à
vivre avec une sorte de couleurs parce
qu'on travaille le corps donc il n'y a
pas le choix de finalement parfois un
peu appuyé là où ça fait mal mais c'est
pas dans un côté
bourreau de soi faut savoir aussi
s'écouter
non ça disons j'espère que je serai sur
scène avec plein de projets que je
puisse en vivre au moins un minimum même
si c'est pas forcément évident
et voilà heureusement
[Musique]